fantastics always like obviously you
nominated for awards this academy award
you had for a Golden Globe is why I must
be very excited about that as we are
what was it like doing the training as a
real pilot for this oh it's fun I mean I
got a great job I get to drive trains
and you know get well I didn't fly a
plane but I got to get in those flight
simulators that the actual pilots are
trained on so it's I got a great job
kind of flying experiences you how does
a passenger be had any kind of
hair-raising one yeah yeah nothing like
this obviously but because I'm here
talking to you right the time to worry
about flying is when you're on the
ground
there's no point worrying about it when
you're in there is too late gotta keep
hoping you stay in the end that's in
fact one flight was was so rough I
accurately had to you know I was on a
private jet and I had to calm the flight
attendant down she was I'm like you
supposed to be helping me she was she
was freaking out I was like it's alright
just sit down we're gonna be alright and
I started talking to her I had to sit
down next to me and just relaxing what
did you learn from playing a character
whip in flight and what would you like
audiences to take away from the movie
it's about more than just addiction but
I never tried to suggest what the
audience should learn you know I don't
want to feel like oh this is a message
and this is what you should get you know
it's it's a very good film very
excellent excellent script great
director excellent performances Kelly
Riley and all John Goodman so just enjoy
the flight you often play morally
ambiguous flawed characters in your
movies you think of things like American
Gangster and training too and of course
flight what is it that attracts you to
those characters well I mean you know
that's it's it's never black and white
how y'all doing back there you're right
it's never one or the other I mean you
know that those are the more interesting
characters there's this writer John
Gaines is did a brilliant job and when I
read it I signed on immediately when Bob
Zemeckis read it he signed on
immediately so it's just that's rare you
know to get get go
like this tell me about the crash
sequence in flight what was it like
filming that well you know when I saw
the finished film I mean we when we were
doing our part we were just on stage but
green-screen you know sort of going
around like that so it was a whole lot
more you know in post-production they've
got two guns coming up later this year
with Mark Wahlberg tell me a bit more
router jokes guns and jokes
you